hola buenas noches así es en la comisión
del debate presidencial tomó esta
decisión después de que presidencia
donald trump viera positivo al
coronavirus y básicamente no consultó
con las dos campañas de manera previa
simplemente cambió al formato a un
formato virtual lo cual significa que
será una especie de town cool en donde
los dos candidatos tendrían que estar en
ocasiones separadas y solo el que hace
las preguntas estaría desde miami lo
cual era el formato inicial la campaña
de baire en el demócrata dijo que
participaría con gusto pero en el caso
del presidente de donaldson aseguró en
sus cuentas en sus redes sociales que de
ninguna manera lo haría y que esto sería
una pérdida de tiempo a esto se le sumó
que el director de la campaña del
presidente de donald trump aseguró que
esto simplemente era una movida para
favorecer a bailén
lo cierto es que hay incertidumbre
frente a la decisión que tomó la
comisión con base también en que el
presidente de donald trump no ha querido
dar información sobre su estado de salud
si se ha hecho una prueba reciente o no
para el coronavirus y se ha dado
o negativa igualmente no han seguido las
directrices en materia de salud para
coronavirus de su propia administración
que indican que una persona ha quedado
positivo para el test debe aislarse y
las personas cercanas deben entrar en
cuarentena aún no se sabe si de acá al
15 de octubre que es la fecha prevista
el presidente llegue a decir que dará
este debate o no